what's up MTV Jesse check me out on the
bootleg Kev
podcast all right bootleg Kev podcast
man special guest here welcoming back my
guy Jesse AKA MTV Jesse AKA Bloody
Sunday Jesse Sunday
Etc on and on and on you're looking like
a like you lost like a whole one of
yourselves with this weight loss and
this transformation you look good man
thanks man what how cuz obviously couple
years ago you had kind of like dived in
on like just like redirecting your life
in terms of like getting clean off of
alcohol cuz you were you know you had a
you recognized you had some sort of
problem with alcohol however severe or
not severe it might have been yeah it
feels like you've dived all the way in
on like kind of a lifestyle change in
terms of fitness and I always see you
sparring and you're just always sweating
and uh you know shirtless sweating and
shirtless but but what well first of all
obviously what sparked that and how long
has The Journey been for for you where
you really like are very consistent cuz
it's you could start most people start
and stop start and stop start and stop
yeah the consistency is important that I
think that was the big change is cuz I
was that guy I mean I've lost 30 to 50
pounds like 10 times in my life and I
[__] got sick and tired of being that
guy likewise yeah you know what I mean
it's [__] annoying I mean even just
this last week that went by I like I
went on the scale after like my dad was
down and like whatever and I'm like 7
lbs heavier and I just cold stop was
like yo you're not that guy like you're
not bouncing back to being like [__]
yeah cuz you could slip into it dude so
quick Y and uh and I think it's when uh
you stop say like for me I I weigh
myself every Monday and I'm like it's
the second you're like no I know I'm
heavier this week so I'm going to weigh
myself next Monday I think that's D
youself go weigh yourself look at it
write it down and then be like get back
like and also weigh yourself at night
cuz if you weigh yourself in the morning
Fu that I can't do I do I'm naked you're
naked TR take as many as soon as you
wake up and you're naked you're like I
don't know why it is if you weigh
yourself like right when you wake up you
weigh way less oh yeah crazy you look
even better you do I know you'll be like
damn like my food processed I'm I don't
have a I'm not I don't have a food baby
right now I even make sure after my
shower I'm like fully dry I can't have
wet hair yeah because it's a little
extra weight yeah damn I sh my pubes I
[__] just listen it all counts he
said my pubes are going down the do you
shave your pubes over the toilet
or in a trash bag let me think it's been
a minute actually cuz that was a joke
let me think oh I mean I gota ask I
think over a toilet you got to do over
the toilet yeah you don't want to be the
guy shaving your pubes over the trash
and then like yeah wait wait I have a
wife over the toilet someone does it
over the trash I don't think I've ever
done that I think I think some people
have done that
actually my uh co-host little brother
did that they they share a place on my
radio show and he talked about how his
uh little brother shaved his pubes and
it was all over the side of the trash
can Cannon and uh you got to clean up
after too cuz it's always around the
toilet seat you got to do the little
youer yep you got to get the it's almost
like a paper towel is more stickier than
you imagine when you're cleaning pubes
off of a toilet SE yeah it grabs them it
grabs them man it does n it's it's dope
to see everything going on with you man
obviously the last time you were on the
show was not too far after we launched
the show I mean it was maybe like four
or five months after we launched the
podcast yeah um it's been a minute man
it's been a minute that was like kind of
right after you
um not right after you had left NE but I
guess you had kind of broken your
silence it was right after you dropped
the first YouTube video kind of talking
about of the new like direction of
content that you were doing yeah um and
I don't think I've I sold the company at
that point though no you did not no that
is correct because shortly after that we
had me and you had started collabing on
some pranks um we had some of the best
dude best episodes we ever did was I get
stopped all the time really and they're
always like dude the prank with the guy
who who wrapped like a bear and and and
and a koi fish and and Simba my boy you
know Simba who's huge you know at the
time he was on the come up he still is
on the come up but he's a lot bigger
than he was then he even brings that
[__] up to me he'll be like dude that
[__] was crazy like people still ask me
about like about that whole situation
really there was a Snow the Product one
we did that for whatever reason that was
with Steve right it was with Steve and
for whatever reason the like real
version of that prank did not
drop I think I don't know was it cuz it
was I think it was like we shot it as a
nek video well that's what I was going
to say I I think you guys had shot
something and I think at that at that
time that was like a situation where
Steve was in it and I think they they
the real footage of that was supposed to
possibly come out on nek yeah but we had
like a kind of a diet version Oh I think
think I know what happened that was
around um cuz like me and Kyle were kind
of shooting our own things anyways it
wasn't very public but like yeah so the
idea was towing cars as a prank and so I
went to you and we shot that we brought
Steve and we had a segment we were going
to do for the video but then I think
they got sued or someone got I think
like the team got arrested for that
prank I think and then that's they
couldn't upload the footage or or they
couldn't finish so there's like really
dope footage of this Snow the Product
prank that we'll never see the light of
day yeah it was really good she I got it
on some drives probably she had like her
Jeep was hooked onto a tow truck and she
was trying to back out and the wheels
were spinning and she's like freaking
out she has her girlfriend in the car
and uh I think Steve was just saying the
most disrespectful sexist [__] to this
it was hilarious it was so
funny he was like talking about like
well yeah I know girls can't drive I
mean you're a woman oh that's what it
was yeah yeah it was it was Peak Peak
Steve will do can't let you drive
because you're a woman 100% it was it
was good man um it that that's what I
was going to say man recently obviously
uh it was so awesome to
see uh obviously the long way everybody
ever since the full send podcast launch
was waiting on you to go on there so it
was dope to see you guys chat and kind
of talk about um the good old days and
some of the early pranks that you guys
had and then they kind of you gave it a
listen yeah I watched the whole thing
yeah I think the day it dropped uh and
then I watched the uh the New York one
where you guys were security guards oh
yeah yeah very it just was like
nostalgic I get a lot of people have hit
me up since that video and been like
yeah it was like the perfect nostalgic
thing to do together that like brought
back like cuz a lot of people I think
they they got brought into NK because of
that Coachella video we did so it was
like their like first [__] thing they
seen so they were just stoked to see
that yeah I just like I think that
that's what I miss you guys I just miss
that kind of content because it doesn't
really exist anymore and I don't think
Kyle's focused on making that kind of
[__] anymore and so it was just dope to
see you know what I mean feeding off
each other kind of yeah and he just you
know like I I I just think some of you
guys' pranks were just some of the best
[__] like you guys would really like you
know whether it's you and and uh Steve
obviously Steve's face I don't even
think it'd be shown anywhere on YouTube
from what I've heard right not even his
hand man it's [__] sad not even his
hand apparently I heard that yeah was
talk about doing a podcast with him or
something and like he' be off camera and
like or that's what it was I think he
did the Donald Trump one or something
happened and his hand was in it and they
were like flagging it and it was like
what it's [__] Bonkers dude that poor
guy man I really feel bad for him
because
like such a sweet dude dude and he was
doing so much like look he was doing
some like pushing the limit type [__]
but he also was giving away so much
money to like random families like I
remember he had that random lady he was
taking on the road with him everywhere
the black chick like I always thought I
mean I mean I I I miss him on YouTube I
haven't checked him out on Rumble to see
if the pranks or the videos are still of
of uh the quality that they were but
when you're deplatformed it's hard to I
don't know
likee I think it was cuz it was his like
audio but then they were like oh he's
not in it and then they said no like I
think they used like his hand being I
could be [__] wrong but I remember
hearing that somewhere but well um how
how good did it feel for you to kind of
uh give the fans some transparency you
know and and so good I bet right [__]
cuz it was a long time coming I remember
uh we shot a video on the Sunday Channel
like driving up to the house to go do it
yeah and uh they were just like flogging
me like the team and I said this like
thing and it's so true I was like I'm so
glad that this is the [__] full sand
podcast that we're going to do where
we're like we're cool and we're like
like we're in good terms me and Kyle and
like not that we're we were in bad terms
but like it was definitely we went
through deal yeah it was a [__] thing
and I didn't want it to be some [__]
mess on the internet like you see a lot
of people who are in this social media
game and it's like they almost ride it
as like oh those so it's like I we could
use this for views yeah and neither of
us like even him like we both were like
this is some business [__] we're going
to figure this out and then I don't know
we did and now we're cool it's like I
mean I think it's a mix of like
reconnecting with him personally for me
but reconnecting with the whole team
shooting a prank again doing the podcast
being able to like actually say how it
is to all my audience and Their audience
and our old fans and like dude it just
feels like it literally felt like a
weight off my back cuz like you know
it's like drinking and lifestyle and
friends and everything that I fixed in
my life there was like that one thing
that I was like needing to knock off the
[__] list it just feels like it's
done now yeah and I think it's cool too
because now you guys can like I feel
like you guys were purposely kind of
like you know I think Kyle did a good
job of not speaking too much on it and I
think even I heard in an interview or
somewhere he had said I don't really
want to dive into it until yeah I talk
with Jesse on the podcast that's the
fans deserve that you know what I mean I
think it was that money buys happiness
podcast he like yeah cuz I watched that
and I was like oh [__] I guess this is
where it's all coming out and then he
was just like he's always just been
respectful that way and I'm like that's
why I've treated him the same way 100%
yeah I think it's dopee just to see that
man and like you said the fans get a
little closure cuz you got share fans I
mean obviously you are when I think of n
boys I think of you and him that's who I
think of and Steve to you know to an
extent you know um but it's dope man um
for you though
like have you gotten the itch to like
kind of you know maybe pop in a video
here and there you know like yeah the he
so Kyle hit me up and was like after we
shot that obviously like the fans were
cool with it like everyone everyone
liked it yeah and he was just like dude
I'm just going to let you know every
time we're shooting a video what we're
doing like and if you want to get down
yeah pop into whatever you want so um
yeah that's that's dope I haven't shot
anything else since that but cuz
obviously I'm I'm like pretty locked
into a [__] schedule with what I'm
building clo the new clothes the new
brand mhm mhm so many I won't even call
it a clothing brand it's just a brand
yeah a lot of things I saw on
Xbox that [__] was sexy super crazy yeah
yeah craziest Xbox I've ever seen this
[__] would you guys have to take it
apart paint it or did somebody do it for
you yeah I had to go through like a
middleman company to buy the Xboxes and
then and then they did it designed them
oursel and then we got them to like like
do it to them but we're doing the same
thing with uh cuz we have a '90s drop
coming out and uh we're doing uh 10 Game
Boy Colors oh so it's kind of sick it's
like Game Boy Color but in our color
it's going to be sick that's great um
yeah so for you now you just kind of
have the option whenever you want to
film hey yeah I want to do the Bigfoot
thing or yeah yeah which is like I never
didn't want to do pranks that's why I
did [__] hole why I did about say when
you were doing [__] hole you did some
great [__] like um you had the old man
that I just saw at a random restaurant
in the valley oh eaten Park in Burbank I
was there with my parents and I saw that
old dude who was like oh Gramps yeah
yeah yeah yeah Gramps and I was just
like that's the dude well he's like a
straightup actor in tons of [__] he's a
great [__] actor but yeah know I saw
him I was like that's the [__] old
man from the [__] uh the the the Jess
videos yeah yeah I mean [__] hole was
dope I mean for you at the
moment documenting kind of the new what
Sunday is right the brand you've been
putting so much into so much work into I
told you off camera I was like it's
crazy because I kind of feel like I've
just been
watching this thing since like
incubation just come live on YouTube and
now you're obviously having success you
had the pop-up shop yeah um Rose it
feels like everything's just flying I
mean you know you droping it out yeah um
and uh for you like I guess what is
your you have so much going on you train
you're working out you got the brand
you're shooting Vlogs content all of
that what is kind of like your like most
of your energy going into cuz you also
eventually want to kind of help do stuff
for other brands right yeah we're
currently already doing that right now
oh dope just we uh we slow down at the
start like the like you were saying You'
seen like you it feels like you like
know Sunday from the start you can like
feel how the whole operation works we
got like I've said this before but like
that's why we got so much hate on it cuz
it was like we were so transparent that
we like didn't even know what the
[__] company was like we were
figuring it out and people were seeing
us figure it out which again I think
long term is paying off cuz now people
are like whoo now I now I understand all
the moving Parts but um yeah the the
only thing with the working for other
people and designing their [__] is it is
super complicated
unless if you do if you do six out of 10
things for that company and they
commission you to do that but then they
[__] up the other four and it doesn't
sell or it doesn't work they want yeah
and they want to blame you for not
working and you're like well you didn't
know how to Market or you didn't know
how to you know whatever it was whatever
it so I think the key is coming in and
in the future it'll be like Venture
Studio absorbing companies like taking
half their company small that we believe
in and so that we care build them up
yeah we can do everything for them but
like if you kind of become a partner and
you make it vertical like fully vertical
and don't do too many of them just like
true yeah don't take on too much cuz
then you're going to I mean everything
gets watered down if you're going to do
that you know what I'm saying yo it's
crazy because I remember the way you
were talking about like the blank and
how important it was to find the right
blank yeah and like what like did you
guys have to cuz there's so many blanks
out there there's like Los Angeles
apparel and uh uh is La apparel the big
thick one that I like pause super pause
yeah um but like for you guys SK all all
right so like how did you find the blank
or did you create the blank create
everything's created so everything we
sell is completely custom but it's uh I
would say it it's a Frankenstein of a
bunch of different shirts so like For
That t-shirt it was like it has a little
bit of an acne Studios blank it like
that's where the boxy fit came the the
fabric was like some shirts that we
liked but it was also came down to just
Tyler who was part of our sourcing team
who just he knows every single fabric we
go field Fabrics like we sampled that
shirt like 12 times so it just kept
frankensteining until we were like this
is the perfect shirt at a perfect price
point and do you go to China to feel
Fabrics just curious I haven't yet no
feels he he is our like connection to
that he he's the guy who's got the
Chinese plugs yeah but we're also doing
a lot of [__] domestically too we're
trying to as much as we I mean that's
dope yeah if you don't have to Outsource
that you can support some American
companies why wouldn't you no 100% or
North American companies cuz shout out
to Canada yeah we're all in this
together you know and
Mexico no it's so it's just dope to see
man for you like
uh have you felt cuz I I can only
imagine when you're a part of something
so big like you were and you you
voluntarily walk away MH
um while trying to build your own [__]
there has to be some time whether it's
subconscious or not and and I I don't
really take you as the type of person
like second guess yourself but you can't
help but be like a a normal human being
who goes through normal human emotions
was there ever any point in time where
you you know either one second guest
leaving nek or two
um did you feel like it was just a a
really hard uphill battle to try to get
over kind of being Jesse from the nek
boys as opposed to being Jesse from [__]
hole Jessie from Sunday like yeah I
mean it's kind of two big Parts
obviously it was like such a long thing
to do so it wasn't I did have I
obviously had the feeling of like should
I do this should I not because it went
on for 2 years you know what I mean so
while it did happen and while that break
happened this happy that things going
[__] Bonkers yeah and you you owned a
piece of happy Dad right yeah so you're
you're obviously I mean happy Dad is
[__] everywhere it almost feels like
it's like bigger than anything now that
those guys are a part of so I can only
imagine like like you said like you're
you're kind of like damn like like I
think that's just a human nature thing
to just be like is I mean not to say
necessarily second guessing yourself but
definitely like kind of assessing what's
going on like did I make the right move
and obviously you're in the middle of of
negotiating a buyout I'm assuming yeah
um and I don't know how much I can talk
on it but that like happy Dad full send
milk everything that was happening in
that time everything was being
negotiated so it was like there was a
point where it was like is this like
leaving everything or is this leaving
some or what does this deal look like
and [__] so that's why it was so big
right happy dad's massive it's like
super massive and I think yeah walking
around walking away with happy Dad is
massive and secure for me so wait do you
still own a piece of happy Dad yeah
yeah yeah we're we're sleeping good now
we're good so well I know who to ask to
borrow uh money for a any sort of
clothing venture or Venture in general
or if I want to go get tugged off
somewhere I just say Jesse yo cash at me
80 you got it bud that's crazy there's a
podcast clip of me talking about that
already where I like said about I don't
know it like went viral as
viral a cpon but of talking how I the
but I kep happy Dad and it was so fny
how that was connected to so many people
that I could tell saw that and called me
and started pitching me all their
Ventures and I'm like I'm not that rich
bro like chill out also like dude [__]
off like yeah like I know you saw the
YouTube short and all but like you know
go [__] yourself like everyone wants to
go for lunch all of a sudden you're like
are you pretty like involved or you just
kind of no completely disconnected just
just check yeah shout out to you man
yeah it's funny that you're you don't
drink anymore but you own one of the
biggest Seltzer brands in the world it's
wild and then I've never tried it that's
[__] even more wild yo I
know wild because you had already left
cuz I remember watching them go and do
the tasting and you weren't there yeah
wow I know
sick that's so sick [__] weird yeah
it's cra like I I I own something I've
never tried so you're like yo that's
crazy have you had
any and you know like I think that you
you spoke about it I don't think you
ever were like the type of alcoholic in
which like my uncle or some of my family
members are where like you're like
physically dependent on alcohol to get
through your day and if you were to get
off of it you go through withdrawals and
maybe end up in the hospital but you
were drinking a lot you were partying a
lot it was your
lifestyle have you gotten to any sort of
point where you were vulnerable where
you thought about having a drink at all
yeah definitely not but not in a
negative way more I'm not that's why I
didn't want like people to think you're
like relapsing cuz I don't think that
like I don't look at you as like the guy
who's like I'm sober 3 Years bro like I
got my chip I'm going to meetings I
don't even say sober anymore cuz don't
drink I just don't drink yeah and and
honestly I literally only did it cuz my
mom said to me one time she was like you
don't want to be the guy that can't have
a beer and I knew that it was more of a
lifestyle change I just had to get out
of that lifestyle where that was a part
of my [__] job every day and I think
that I've accomplished that and I feel
healthier and all this [__] so it's been
crossing my mind um just like how long
it's it's weird it's like it's such a
streak now that it's like weird to break
that seal and to be honest I'm a little
worried about how it'll make me feel
like cuz the last time I had like a
couple drinks I like made my head all
[__] up I [__] I don't know it
screwed me up so like the very last time
I drank so I don't know it actually like
scares me a bit to have a drink but
maybe that's good I do you miss like
beer the most honestly maybe a cold beer
but maybe it's just like going over for
dinner and yeah having a glass of wine
feeling a little loose yeah like a
little like social drink you know yeah
yeah that makes sense I I guess if you
were going to break the streak you
should break it for the company that
you're part owner of yeah I'll
definitely have a happy day yeah for
sure the best flavor by the way fruit
punch and I don't even think it's close
I think it's fruit punch and then I
think it's the death Road grape
I heard a lot of people saying that
grape one's great and then it's Pro I'm
not going to lie the first like pack
that dropped I think I only liked one of
them really I think I only like I
haven't had the banana one but I do love
fruit punch is fire really yeah fruit
punch if you're going to break the
streak you got to go fruit punch I got
to send you a case here man I didn't
know you drink it oh yeah yeah yeah
we'll get you some might uh you know I
opened a nightclub in Scottdale and uh
we carry happy Dad I didn't know that
yeah I'll check it out yeah it's a
hip-hop club obviously it's it's it's
not like the Scottdale spots you guys
usually go to that have happy Dad but we
are cracking we just had the baby we
just had sexy red we just I mean it's
it's lit but we do have happy Dad we
carry happy Dad so I've tried them all
but we I think we keep the grape in
stock the grape and the fruit punch
really yeah yeah I wonder how many
[__] stores and clubs and locations
dude it's crazy cuz it's everywhere cuz
I mean I'm sure as you know like when
when you guys I mean you weren't
necessarily heavily involved but you
know it is your company part of it mhm
and when happy Dad first dropped it was
like a real mission to find it like if
you found I remember the liquor store
would be like dude we can't like we get
like 20 cases in and they sell like
right away to like one guy yeah and it
was like what the [__] I'm sure that was
all designed by Kyle like that's where
he's a genius like he just created the
Demand right away made it Limitless it's
almost like a drop style alcohol they
were doing where it be like hey this
location in Orange county is getting
thousand kids outside of there not kids
but 20 21y olds man 21 year olds of
course I'm going to have to be annoying
and take a piss real quick go take a
piss you want to walk over to take a
piss sorry about that man no you're good
yo what up guys we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
my bookie it's winning season right now
NFL we're in the thick of it I've been
doing really good on my NFL bets by the
way plus NBA officially back we got
playoff baseball it's going crazy
especially if you like to throw down
some of that money and do a little
gambling you got to head over to my
bookie uh this was DPE about my bookie
it doesn't matter if your team sucks my
team the Cardinals they're trash don't
matter I'm still winning on Sundays baby
all right at my bookie all right you can
use my bookie for your daily odd boost
same game parlays and take advantage of
the crazy huge prize pool contest plus
right now my bookie has a no strings
attached that's the important thing no
strings attached cash bonus that let you
deposit and withdraw quick that's free
cash no strings attached deposit take it
out and then go about your day or get in
on some of this NFL and NBA action baby
all right just use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up go to my
bookie.ag use the promo code bootleg on
your first deposit and you'll receive up
to $200 in cash what are we talking
about no strings attached what my bookie
use the promo code bootleg all right
maybe you want to gamble on some NFL
maybe you want to get in on some of this
early NBA action maybe you want to get
in on some of this playoff baseball it's
really on you use the promo code bootleg
and receive up to $200 in cash that's
right try my bookie right now use that
promo code bootleg and you can grab um
how about this man there's some crazy
odds going on and I like this one
because what you can do is you can throw
down on a potential Super Bowl front
runner and uh plus 38 8,000 on the
Eagles and Chiefs on the Super Bowl plus
38,000 if you put
$100 you win
$38,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with mybookie plus
we got to give a big shout out to our
family at King pal man we love King pal
over here on the bootle C podcast this
is what's great about King pom first of
all it's all about that organic no
tobacco leaf this thing right here is a
boy look at that that's just a leaf
right there King pal they got everything
you need man they got these cones with
the squeez and pop tpin in them the
flavors this right here is the uh the
dragon fruit we got the grape HD the
watermelon wav so many flavors what's
dope about King pal if you're in
whatever City you're in you could find
King pal at your local smoke shop your
local 71 all right I'm telling you King
pom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke what you're
smoking all right you stuff one of these
boys up with some flour uh and and you
just you're Off to the Races I'm telling
you you hit the tip you get hit with
that flavor and it's man it's nothing
like it the squeezing pop on King pal is
insane all right and they got all size
cones all right so go to King pom man
organic tobacco free leaes of all sizes
like this is a this is a this is look
look we're talking about all sizes here
what are we talking about what are we
talking about here boys all right go to
King pom.com right now you can order
whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ashtrays they got damn
all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview all right
we're back
all right my bad the piss has commenced
the piss has commenced um yeah uh I I
think like I think we were talking a
little bit just kind of about like the
process um
obviously uh shout out to happy Dad if
you were to have a drink we'd
established that it would be a happy Dad
you got to try your own [__] 100% um how
like I always wonder when you own a
company like that cuz like I'm part
owner of a nightclub I have certain like
ways I get paid out do you get paid out
quarterly do you get paid out yearly is
it by anually like I think it's uh
yearly but it's
mostly I don't even know how that all
[__] I haven't dove into it too much but
it's more of just like that [__] sells
one day [__] that's more which I'm
sure it will yeah that's yeah know
you're banking on the cell cuz the
cell's got to be coming eventually even
if it's like not anytime soon like it
feels like like the goal if you're like
an upand cominging alcohol company is to
get it super popping and then sell to
like a bardi or like one of these big
dogs that anheiser bush or something and
just cash the [__] out I have a feeling
that that was the the motion I don't
want to speak for anyone but I think
they're seeing how well of a job they're
doing it and they're like maybe this is
a 10year plan maybe this is like they're
going to go for it they're going to try
to be like Budweiser or like I get it I
mean I mean or white white what what's
the other one white claw white claw yeah
what's yeah I mean they have taken that
market share for sure man um for you man
tell me like uh what are you what are
your relationships like like how often
do you talk with a guy like Steve these
days pretty slim with Steve he uh he'll
text me or DM me like a sentence every
once in a while and then I'll be like
like something just out out of the box
random and then I'll hit him back and be
like what's up buddy and then not much
like when he got like deplatformed do
you like feel inclined to like reach out
and like see if he's okay cuz I feel
like yeah for sure as someone with a
YouTube channel and I see certain
people's channels just getting
demonetized or deleted I would like I
don't even know what I would do man like
it'd be heartbreaking well for him it's
like it's not even because of financial
really I think it's more just he loved
like dude he he literally did love doing
that like he loves doing [__] for people
and giving to people and I think that
the show that he was doing gave him a
purpose to keep doing that and I think
he just loved being a YouTuber and a
Creator like and I'm sure that that's
that's a toll man when someone takes
that away from you it [__] sucks so I
do feel for him man for sure man
definitely sucks um talk to me about for
you like the Sunday thing what is the
what how did cuz there had to be a few
names in the running for your new brand
mhm give me kind of a few of the other
names that almost made it and why did
you end up kind of landing on Sunday
other names I honestly don't think there
was there wasn't anything that that that
you were like you know what let's put
that on the Whiteboard because I like it
just put it down there just because I
want to see it
well it starts with Bloody Sunday which
I've had for a while it's also got my
own little personal meaning that I don't
make public but the
like then it just it's kind of like when
they I think it was like Facebook was
called like the Facebook and then they
like slimmed it up so like Bloody Sunday
being the streetwear brand which started
as shoes that I worked on for like 5
years just in just as a hobby I just was
well like you had dropped backpacks like
what a year year and a half ago there
was like real highend
just just like I was for
homies um Sunday it just it really hit
me that one time with like I don't know
if I've already explained this or if you
know this already but the whole idea of
I like to look at life as like chapters
a bit and Sunday is like this chapter
that I'm on and it kind of felt like nek
was a Friday night the vibe of a Friday
night Saturday was full s it's like keep
going and then Sunday was like
everything you just think and feel when
you think of Sunday is like what we
represent and what I represent and what
I'm trying to build it into is just
like that like relaxing but it's like a
little um like a Tempo down you know
what I mean but it's also like I don't
know I'm going to butcher explaining
this but it's just I know it's like I
know what it means to me and it just it
I know it makes sense well you guys like
really mastered
somehow the culture that you created and
and turning it into like an
exclusive brand that was kind of like a
supreme if you will when certain drops
would like I think you guys would drop
with uh full s was it every month almost
yeah month it was like a monthly drop
and I and and like I I'm I'm assuming
that you guys had opportunities to make
it not so exclusive and ended up in a
Tilles or aumi or something and I'm
assuming you guys probably we smart
enough to be like no we we like what
we're doing it keeps our brand super
exclusive we don't want to wh it out
yeah um for you is that something you
want to kind of carry over with Sunday
like cuz it feels super exclusive like
it's almost like this is going to get
made and if you don't get it you're
never going to get it cuz it's not
getting made ever again 100% that's
that's the only business model I know
for creating Brands and what I'm good at
but I also I do I don't want to create
something that's also like 15-year-old
me camp be a part of because I miss the
drop or it's too expensive so I'm
keeping that in mind and that's where
there's a lot of different lanes that
we're building out that like that's why
I think it's like so smart with Sunday
being the catalog dropping in the color
MH and then that that enters that piece
into the catalog like now we can use
that to design for years going forward
but the idea that that drops in the
green and that's Sunday and that's
always the most limited like it happened
with our last drop every Sunday skew
sold out in like a minute under a minute
and I think that then Sunday can kind of
become that that you know special
limited never happens again Bloody
Sunday can be just as special but little
easier to get little easier to get and
and then it's not like out yet but I've
been working in the background for I'm
trying to make up another brand that's
like a sister brand that's in the
company same culture same designers
everything but it isn't uh it's a little
inexpensive it's like and I'm working on
it with um possibly like a Tilles or
zumies and something yeah but it's a
brand for it it's called and it's we
literally cuz we were talking we were
like what about can't afford this what
about can't and we were like like the
everyday kid that I was going sit at the
skate shop and I'm like I want to create
a brand that's just as cool and you can
feel a part of the party but it's not
about always just like selling out and
limited and you know High margins it's
just it's like everyday brand for but
still has the culture of what we are you
know yeah and like you you're very good
at like creating a like that's why I
said earlier it's not it's not a
clothing brand because you you've always
been really good at just kind of just
having just [__] like if you want a
[__] Flag or you want I
mean what is this a lanyard yeah like a
lanyard you know what I mean like it
doesn't always have to be like hats and
shirts and [__] like no it kind of like
that's what fascinates me though like I
love how finding new [__] like what if
we did our version of this like why
can't we make our own mics why can't we
make our like when you find out that
like how that shit's made what is the
minimum otor like what can you customize
on this that's why the Sunday Brand's so
fun cuz everything has to be in the
color so when you look at like a mic
like this there like St wood steel how
like then oh if you want to change the
steel you got to hit 10,000 mq it's like
[__] I don't know I find all that the
logistics of it super interesting damn
but I don't know if I answered anything
you asked no that sounds great no I I
just I I just feel like it's dope to
kind of Cu like you've done such a good
job of like building Brands you know
obviously I give you a lot of credit and
Kyle a lot of credit for the nek [__]
but I feel like just the clothing [__] I
knew when you had initially quote
unquote broken off from filming it was
to focus on the clothing side and
building out the the the merch more and
[__] so I know that it's very you know I
think that's what flicked a bell for me
is when that happened and cuzz I got to
remember that when I was a kid that's
where it all started it was
skateboarding filming skateboarding and
creating clothing like I was a kid
selling clothes out of my locker trying
to make that work and I just always
loved it and I think that just made me
realize if that had a point in my life I
was unhappy I'm like this [__] makes me
happy I want to I like I could wake up
every day and just work on like
designing clothes and making products
and think the marketing of it right
that's kind of like the everyone's dream
can I wake up every day and what makes
me happy and and get paid for it and it
be it's silly to be like financially
secure and then not do that that's right
like that was my uh my Tipping Point of
just like what am I doing like um so one
one of my favorite parts of uh the nek
era was when your dad Pat would be in in
the videos cuz I just think he's [__]
sick he just seems like a sick hang I I
met him a couple of times I met him when
you were in the studio with casy yeah um
how involved do you have him involved
and you said he was just here for few
weeks is he involved with anything with
the brand or you know is he just dead at
this point like just just character I
think yeah like for one I mean I just
bought a home so it's been cool to have
them down and like I'm trying to make a
real effort of how important that's
going to be just being able to like work
on my first house and it's a fixer upper
so just like great I used to do that
when I was a kid with him and I know
that uh so he's like a contractor yeah
or like he's like a handy Manish right
yeah yeah he'll he'll he'll the only
problem with him is he's going to find
like the cheapest way to do everything
shout out yep that sounds like me and
I'm not trying to lose value on that
home so I'm like I'm trying to always
push him I'm like no man like yeah we
let do this the right way Dad yeah let's
do it the right way know I mean things
are good right now we don't have to we
don't have to cut corners but I
definitely am carrying over the
character when it comes to like the
Sunday show and what we're doing and I
mean I think I we found that with NE is
just the the father Son comedy and
father son being my dad being a father
figure to like now
was what was so funny and also just like
good for those guys like they've came to
me and him numerous times when we were
on those trips and was like I don't know
whether it was like some don't talk to
their dad a lot or have a close
relationship it's just like it's good I
mean I even get a lot of comments about
that whenever they see like footage of
me and my dad and it's honestly like
dude it's like the saddest [__] when
someone says like I don't I never got I
don't get to do that with my dad so I
look forward to those watch dude yeah
that's like want to hit on my [__]
heartstrings that's like dude that's
[__] I don't know that makes me want
to shoot more content with him if it's
like I love his IG man especially when
he's like in his little fold up chair
he's in the garage
you anytime I try to produce his [__]
it's horrible when I just say Do What
You Do here's your you have to know how
to work your phone it always works huh
yeah and he'll just he just makes like a
peaky Blinder set I don't know if you
saw that one yeah I saw it py blinders
is no one's even talking about it it
happened 10 years ago it's over it's
overo little research it's going to hit
Netflix but yes yeah yeah fair enough
but he watched it that week so he's like
peeky Blinder set it's crazy because I'm
I'm sure you probably have heard from
fans of what you did
prior you had to have heard from some
people like did you inspire anybody to
quit drinking at all like yeah that was
a especially near the the start of it
all I was having people like come up to
me and dude like the saddest one when I
was in Hermosa Beach in this it's not
sad it's just this [__] always hits me
but like this mother came up to me and
was yeah same whole story just like her
son was relapsing like a bunch and um
that he's been sober for x amount of
months because of you and [__] it's
just like and that's around the time
where I was going through a lot of [__]
and like you said like am I making the
right decision and I remember I just
like that's all I needed I was like yep
I'm doing the right thing right now like
even if you just help that one kid
though that's crazy like you said not
that there's any problem with drinking
but I do think that like at the end of
the day it is it is a behavior that if
you let it get out of hand it it will
negatively affect your life yeah it
could it could make you get a DUI that
you shouldn't have got it could make you
make a decision I mean everyone's one
decision away from [__] their whole
entire life up at any given time right
so it's like that that your ability to
make that [__] up decision is however
much more likely because you're
intoxicated right so it's like that's
where the anxiety comes from cuz it's
the like yeah like I I get it I'm sober
now and I think it's just a tick that
I've brought over but [__] the idea
of oh crashing my car or doing like it's
just like one second it could ruin your
[__] life and I just I think that if
you are living that lifestyle there
nothing wrong with drinking but if
you're deep into it where you're [__]
doing it every day or you're blacking
out a lot dude like you slip up once
it's just yeah because when you like
we've all had those nights or those
friends where you black out drunk and
you literally say I don't know know what
happened last night imagine not knowing
what happened the entire night and day
prior because you were so [__] up you
could have did anything that was my
problem I was a blackout drunk like I
never I don't know if I was really an
alcoholic I was a [__] just like I
was a life of the party so I if I was
going to drink I would just drink and
how how um it's it's it's interesting to
just kind of see how the world has
turned in the last three years in terms
of like just everything obviously uh
coid was crazy but you guys I want to
say the tail end of what before you had
kind of stepped away was those early
coid videos yeah which were great
because if I curiously living in La
watching you guys party in like the
Ozarks or wherever the [__] you guys
were was sick how like were were those
like was I that had to be a stressful
time to shoot because oh yeah we don't
know all the information everyone's
freaking freaking the [__] out I mean I
think fast forward to now we probably
have all come to the conclusion that
everything's all right and if you get Co
chances are you'll be okay yeah if
you're healthy it's probably a cold
we're fine right but at that time it's
like Peak hysteria like early peyer and
you guys are hitting the road doing
these just these weekend [__] just
insane binges um there only so many
lecture videos you can do and like we
were doing a lot of like you guys doing
a lot of the the popping in on the zoom
yeah yeah yeah so so like what what was
it like hitting the road during that
time where was everyone freaked out like
worried about catching Co or didn't I
don't think so I mean we had a massive
team so it was we were still taking like
I would love to know what we spent on
just testing and like right cuz
everybody had to test yeah we were
testing all the time tests were
expensive oh yeah it was crazy you
couldn't go to Walgreens and get a test
yeah but we had to keep the company a
going it kind of reminds me of like UFC
and one that they did they were like the
one organization that was like we're not
going to just like say [__] the rules
but we're going to like find a way to
make this work cuz I'm running a company
WWE did that too yeah did they yeah yeah
they had like a they had a it was kind
of corny like WrestleMania during the
pandemic was like a ring surrounded by a
bunch of screens of fans watching on
Zoom oh so it looked like real fans in
the kind of I mean it just looked like
thousands of people sitting in their
chair on their webcam so it kind of but
there was no noise so there's no crowd
noise or anything oh [__] so it's like
quiet people just hitting the mat and
then you just see like people like react
like a half a second late you know cuz
it's like not everybody's got the best
internet out there and that must have
been weird for UFC when they were doing
it in Vegas a lot yeah like imagine
you're used to massive crowds reacting
quiet de quiet you can hear the other
coach you can hear your coach it almost
kind of feels like it could [__] your
whole like oh yeah if you're like used
to fighting that like with the noise and
[__] and it's just dead quiet like and
you could hear everything like you could
hear the commentators and [__] like it's
a little too I want to say serious but I
mean when we Spar we Spar every Friday
and like you got tunes on there's people
like it's like it's a Vibe I couldn't
imagine just dead quiet two people
trying to kill each other at a chicken
what is are you doing Jiu-Jitsu um
mostly just striking so kickboxing
boxing Muay Thai type [__] or just
whatever just UMX Muay Thai definitely
like it's like very useful style but the
I really want to start doing a little
bit more um
ground game and just maybe even a day a
week jiujitsu yeah uh my boy so I I
train in the morning I don't do jiujitsu
but I train I work out with my guy esot
at a Jiu-Jitsu gym oh nice and
so I just don't know if I could roll
around with another grown man in some of
those compromising positions no one
talks about how it's pretty gross too
like you're covered in sweat and you're
sweating and there's staff infection
there's dude that's all that's part of
that culture ring yep someone comes in
they got a Band-Aid on their neck and
you're like oh cool like yeah and it's
like you know like uh dudes will sweat
in your mouth like unfortunately it's
like unavoidable right well J Jitsu jyms
it's normally like 20 dudes 10 people
you know like I don't know if they call
it sparring I think they call it rolling
or rolling yeah and but then they'll go
okay the switch Partners so now you're
just like covered in sweat on a sweaty
map all everyone's sweat is
cross-pollinated
it's gnarly you have to buy like special
soap to like it's like I forget what
it's called but it's almost like you're
you're very dependent on a lot of people
to be taking care of their hygiene at a
high level 100% And the chances of that
being the case are very slim cuz people
are dirty as [__] I recommend just
finding a your cool group of people that
you love and training with them that's
what I do like this morning uh one of
the guys who's the main coaches at it's
a place called Legacy in Burbank he
always comes in and talks [__] to me cuz
he says I look like some [__] bald
fighter I don't know
so I went to go back and talk [__] to
him but he was rolling and he had this
dude on top of him with his legs open
and I was just like Jesus I couldn't do
it I couldn't do it man like just I get
the Striking I get that the Muay thae
the fighting you know but Jiu-Jitsu is
just just a special kind of dedication
isn't it weird that hobbies and sports
have to feel cool for you to be
interested like in a weird way like I
skated my whole life but I wonder if how
much percent of that was because I
skateboarding felt cool it like it was
it was during that era it was like it
was the [__] yeah and I think
the boxing it feels cool like I don't
it's a cool thing right now for sure I
feel like and and that you're right like
I kind of feel like MMA like even my kid
who just turned 18 asked me he's like
he's a big UFC fan he was just like hey
uh you know can you see how much it
would cost to put me in because he plays
basketball and stuff but he wants to do
uh Jiu-Jitsu yeah and I was like you
know it's it's pretty gnarly I mean I'm
I'm all for it cuz I know it you know
with any sort of martial arts there's a
certain level of discipline that comes
with it and camaraderie and it's good
for you you know for you like you don't
necessarily like do you do you have like
a I wouldn't say a Sensei but do you
have like like do you train like to like
level up in belts or you just kind of
doing it strictly as like a passive
hobby like we Spar we hang out like I
work on just I have a coach and stuff
but it's yeah there's no belts in what
I'm doing or anything but uh yeah
there's no real goal I just love it I'm
only 2 years in but yeah are you skating
more or yeah trying to I took a little
break there and I'm I'm uh I'm trying to
make like a at least like two days a
week I mean I have a [__] ramp at my
warehouse like use it you know like dude
I don't know if you've been to isumi
recently but I went and they have the
[__] OG Osiris's in there oh the big
chunky ones the big chunky Osiris's the
d3s they're in there and they have like
they're making a comeback all like the
es shoes like they have like yeah y mus
just dropped one with I'm like yo this
is the same [__] [__] like they're
just red it's almost like vintage
Jordans yeah like they're retro all
these skate shoes from like when I was
in high school and in middle school and
it's just crazy to see cuz like even
some of the like balenciagas which I
think are [__] gross but even like
some of those high-end Brands they're
just stealing like what the skate Brands
were doing in the [__] late '90s
early 2000s well I think it's dumb on
their like I've seen all the designer
Brands drop their $1,200
basically Osiris and d3s but like they
don't if they think they're going to
grab the poor skate culture Market by
doing that those guys are like no like
they I don't know I think it's just a
dumb it's like maybe the people that
want to bite on that skate culture will
wear them but no skaters buying an
$1,100 pair of knockoff heavy they're
like bricks too I've tried putting them
on and they're [__] like they're
almost like what am I supposed to do
with these like yeah yeah shoes are
weird when you get into highend like
they actually become uncomfortable
they're [__] I don't know like they
they still like these I wear these a lot
these are St lauron but they're the
simplest mhm like designer shoe I could
find that feels like like a nice Vans
you know what I mean another nice van
yeah but they still Scuff the same that
I would rather have a brand new pair of
Vans every month than having one of
these scuffed up in a month for a year
you know what I mean for sure yeah I
haven't yet I don't have any designer
shoes I only have Jordans and dunks and
vans stay that way they're they're
[__] I've tried to dable on them when
I was building that like I was making my
own shoe and I just I bought every
single pair that I you know what's crazy
is it it how how truly impossible it
feels to start a new shoe company oh
that's insane it's almost like an
impenetrable Market that it's like
almost impossible to get a market share
to make it worth all of the while and
all of the overhead because shoes are
not like there t-shirt brands that print
to order right yeah you can't do that
with a shoe yeah so no matter what
you're sitting on a size run yeah so and
I've seen friends of mine who have
started independent shoe companies that
are [__] awful and they just eat [__]
on it because it's like dude you had to
print out how you had to get however
many pairs of these shoes made dude I
know everything about this it's there's
a reason why there's like six companies
controlling the whole Market it's
[__] like a mold is5 to $15,000 per
size
so you go in and you got 13 sizes you
got half sizes like you do the math like
if you don't have half a million dollars
to you're not even in the game to even
like try and then where if they don't
hit like it's the whole thing so but
we've like there's nothing really public
about what we were doing but dude we've
like we're almost going uh it's nothing
visually looking like a Croc but the
Croc business model is kind of what
we're we're seeing something there's
something there we're trying to make
like the next like what in 10 years will
be the next fans or Air Force One the
simple everyday man I was going to say
it's funny cuz like uh any of the new
shoes that have spiked up have been have
you seen those like bubble slides oh
yeah they're like super cheap on Amazon
my kid has like nine pairs of them cuz
he sees them on YouTube and Tik Tok and
so that's the most inexpensive basic
yeah same thing with a Croc like it's in
inexpensive basic if like if you're
going to try to compete with like Jordan
like good luck yeah you know what I mean
it's just it's not going to be easy yo
we got to stop the interview again and
tell you about our folks at odd Soxs
baby that's right shout out to odd Soxs
man the most comfortable socks in the
world they've been riding with us since
day one um and let me tell you something
man Christmas time is is really sneaking
up um oddsocks official.com use the
promo code bootleg save 20% off at
checkout they got the crazy licenses
check out these Naruto socks [__]
fire little SpongeBob socks you know
what I'm saying how about this how about
the how high movie sock sock they got
the WWE they got the [__]
Cheeto socks you know what I'm saying
shout out to the [__] Cheeto
socks they just dropped their Monopoly
line too I'm waiting for them to send
them to me Ahmad send me the Monopoly
[__] buddy all right also the odd Sox
Basics these are my favorites they're
just normal just you know the most
comfortable socks you've ever put on
your feet is really what they are get
them black white red [__] tie-dye
whatever you're into and they got the
underwear baby L Reese's boys let's go
odd Soxs official.com use the promo code
bootleg they got South Park underwear
too all the licenses WWE Scarface
Breaking Bad South Park Power Rangers
Monopoly cocacola they got it all use
that promo code bootleg and save 20% off
at checkout also want to give a shout
out to our sponsor uh much love to our
good Folks at bluechew that's right we
talk about it all the time on the
podcast when you go to blue.com right
now you can get your first month for
free a lot of people ask well what is
blue and does it work well bluechew it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and Calis the only difference is you
don't have to go to the doctor it's all
online you go to blu.com you get your
[__] handled over there and then they
get you handled by sending you a month
for free when you use the promo code
bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg try
out blue Chu it'll have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh blue will have you right
like I said same active ingredient as
viagran Calis minus the awkward doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discreet packaging blue chewable form
it's in a little it's a little chewable
man you take that thing down and then
you go to Pound Town take your shorty to
Pound Town godd damn it bluechew.com use
that promo code bootleg try it for free
for a month let's get back to the
interview I think it's about Simplicity
for sure price point and yeah really
ability too cuz people start new shoe
companies and they try to do too much
that's what I was going to bring up is
everyone I know that starts their own
shoe company does way too much and they
try to be different and then everyone
just they're even if they do pop they're
cool for a [__] month and then no one
cares and you're stuck with a bunch of
molds it's like I think you got to like
simplify it but be unique like what is
actually missing in this in the shoe
industry you know what I mean so 100%
And any with any industry I think people
should ask themselves that question you
know what I'm saying so 100% I'm
definitely going to send you one of the
samples coming because I want to see
okay I need some opinions from all
different cultures of [__] let me know
man I will I will I will wear a 12 a 12
I'm a 12 got you depends on if they're
the Asian sizes cuz if you ever get
bootleg shoes oh really they got the
Chinese size the Chinese size that's
this is not this this is an actual thing
SI 17 no no they're smaller oh really
yeah like if you get like a Chinese
extra large it's like a medium really
yeah I didn't know that yeah it's crazy
it's like so if you're like a fat [__]
yeah and you want to wear fake Gucci
good luck you're they're not they don't
they're not making Chinese 5xl oh so if
you see a fat person wearing Gucci you
know squeez in and you're like they
didn't make that shirt that big they
didn't make that shirt that big that's
another thing like I saw my boy glasses
blowing he was doing this interview and
he was talking about Rick Ross who's a
big guy and he was like and this is
before Rick Ross lost all his weight but
he would pointed out he was like fam
everyone's wearing fake
[__] Lou don't even make the shirt in
the size Rick Ross wears yeah like they
don't make it like they're not making it
just for him you know what I mean oh
yeah which is crazy um I was going to
say for you man like talk about you know
I think it's important for people to
find things that they can gravitate to
that kind of you know I guess double as
a form of therapy you know what I mean
um obviously you're you're you're
sparring you're doing your MMA [__] you
skate um stuff that is obviously a away
from work cuz you're I'm sure you're a
workaholic I'm a workaholic we both bust
our ass but like for you talk about the
therapeutic like um release that you get
from like some of the hobbies that
you've picked up and you know obviously
we've seen
probably I mean it's all of it [__]
running's a big one but running sucks
dude until you get into it I [__]
hated running I hated Runners I thought
the whole thing was so lame think I'm a
skater I'm short I'm built like a
cylinder block dude you're running like
go do something fun why do you have
Brook shoes on yeah and oh speaking of
that my first like 3 months of getting
into running I wore Vans until my
[__] knees and hips hips and
everything started like [__] Vans I
ran in Vans what even right now I think
I'm running in a basketball shoe I like
I don't know I just like I know people
like to lift weight can't wear a running
shoe you can't wear a running shoe I'm
not a running shoe guy there's those
like really fat shoes are they called
hookas or hokas yeah see I bought a pair
of those I just felt goofy in them they
definitely look goofy you you felt goofy
cuz you looked goofy in them yeah but
the practicality of them is supposed to
be you can run in them and I do know fat
people like my boy jelly roll shout out
my brother roll oh he's the man that is
one of his go-to shoes really cuz
they're very comfy I think it goes back
to what I was saying with the sparring
and boxing it's like I if I don't feel
it's not about looking cool but if I
don't feel cool in what like like it's
not even cool it's not the right word
but just like yeah you like I remember
I'd go skating you put on like a dope
outfit you're like I'm going to feel
cool and I have to [__] feel that
when I'm going running too it's like I
don't know you guys should do a um a
Apple watch band a Sunday one yeah I
think so do they change CU we stayed
away from iPhone cases and [__] reason
they they don't so no to get like no not
in the same way in iPhone changes okay
so like I bought this these bands I
think can fit like three generations of
oh nice now the the Apple watch bands
are pretty pretty Universal because they
really only change the um next year are
they changing it big time yeah I know
yeah yeah until you decide to do a
Sunday one and then they they make
little incision and then that goes into
your wrist yeah these things just slide
in and out but let me take a photo of
your wrist so that I remember so it is a
good
idea yeah that'd be nice yeah I think it
the panone I and I love just yeah in a
green what that should a pop any
outfit yeah was there a color that you
almost like was it always like greenish
blue or was there ever like a a a peachy
red or something that y'all [__] with
no it was always green it came from uh
armymen like when I was a kid I always
played with like toy armymen that was
like originally were I really liked it
and then I just also did a lot of
research on has anyone coined a color
like this cuz I really wanted people to
see that color like the only brand that
I've ever seen Do It um is cook cookies
do you know cookies yeah cookies has the
cookies blue yeah okay I they've done a
really good job like if you go to a
cookies dispensary the building is blue
yeah right but it's like a specific just
unique blue I'm assuming did you guys
just throw paint together until you got
the color or was it like um it started
digital so everything was from graphic
design and then the first thing that it
transferred to was fabric so doing a
cotton
t-shirt you also kind of don't know like
how it's going to like look when you oh
100% the shirt dude like like there's
you know 15 of these shopping bags at
our place all in slightly different
shades it's everything's a battle until
you figure it out but then it's like say
you figure out cardboard or card stock
now it's like for any other item that
needs that you've got packaging figured
out fig out yeah so we're kind of
building like a Pantone book for our
company so it's easier you mentioned
buying your house fixer upper
congratulations thank you uh since you
uh obviously sold your part of full s
and nek what has been the most ignorant
purchase you've
made and if not ignorant just the
biggest outside of your home because
your home is obviously your home that's
that's a [__] nut for
sure dude literally nothing I'm trying
to think I have not gone crazy or you
haven't bought the home was the that's
all I wanted I wanted a home and uh
trying to think I mean everything is
just I mean I've got over a million
invested into my company just
reinvesting yeah wow I don't know I
don't really need a lot of [__] I got a
truck but I was still in the company
when I got that got an old your G wagon
Chevy uh you had a G wagon yeah I had a
G wagon I sold that tax right off £6,000
lb yeah that was sick I got a G wagon
off of um what's it called auctions oh
really yeah I got it for like 91 Grand
drove it for 2 years got to experience
the whole G wagon and you get to ride it
off right yeah and then sold it for 100k
two years later made money on it got to
keep it hey I got a everybody always
talks about a it's one of those cards
you grew up looking at yeah yeah so you
just got a big Chevy truck now yeah got
a C10 and then um a Tesla as an everyday
how do you like the Tesla I'm up and
down on it I mean I I think you got a
model X I always get this wrong I have
the the doors don't go up that's the Y
you have the model S not I think I have
the X Y well the x is the one where the
doors go up okay I have the Y okay yeah
the why cuz it's like stubbier it's
almost like SUV kind of no the x is like
the actual SUV but the doors pop open
the x is like the super expensive one
yeah I don't have that yeah yeah I think
I have the Y I've been extremely on the
fence about about it man like I've test
drove one and I'm like this is cool it's
also very like it it has to be weird to
get used to driving that car because
there's buttons andad like like the
stuff you're used to like conventionally
the braking system you is weird it's
just everything's just different right
so it's like but once you get used to it
it does become it's not even it's not in
the realm of cars it's just once you
have one every other car feels weird
it's like weird I was going to say cuz
like even like saving money on gas it's
like do you notice I mean you probably
you're you're doing pretty well but I
think like do you think the everyday
person notices that like they don't have
to fill up their tank but but get a
[__] charger here you just plug it in
every time you pull in I was say but
then if you go on a road trip you got to
kind of oh yeah I've had there's times
where you're like [__] this Tesla I've
been stranded in Arizona and [__] before
it's like cuz the thing is when when
that thing shuts off and runs out of
juice you've ran out yeah oh yeah I had
I had as worse as you can get where the
point where it ran out and we it's you
know it's just got the hazards on but it
took so long for a truck to come the
hazards turned off yeah like even the
backup little battery died so now you
can't even shut the windows you can't
even even if I got I got it to a charger
and I couldn't even get it to start
charging cuz you can't get the door open
it was like an 8 Hour thing it was like
I was like why is this even a thing like
why would they make it where this can
happen I would just be like [__] this
car I'm getting a [__] I'm going to
drive my Chevy everywhere oh yeah every
gas guzzling car you see going by you're
like I [__] just wish I could just
see that you might have just sealed a
deal for me [__] Tesla everyday La
driving though I will say it's nice
you're just driving around like and like
you plug it in a night I'm sure it's
[__] wonderful have another car for
road trips and [__] like that that' be
good Jesus man that's crazy I was going
to ask you uh there when you were with
those guys steiny wasn't around right no
no I think he was working for
um [__] Steve no the uh he might have
worked for Steve too at a certain point
God why am I blanking on his name Jesus
the he he started the podcast with Kyle
John is that his name no no the rich
dude he was a host on the full sent show
oh uh Bob men Bob that guy's a [__]
sick ass dude bro yeah he's hilarious
he's like he's just like
unstable he's a wild boy oh the remote
are you cold are you freezing blowing
directly usually you wouldn't complain
if something was blowing on
you hey you're like hey bro it's it's
too cold in here no that's crazy yeah so
he was working for Bob initially MH yeah
did you did you were you able to kind of
like I watching that podcast by the way
it made me realize he's not like a real
like OG like nek fan
yeah yeah he didn't know too much he
didn't know [__] I was like how do I
know more about this [__] than this kid
he works for them at least if I if I was
working for if I was a part of that
podcast I would I would be well-versed
yeah I would have to go back and do my
research you know but did you game him
up at all cuz he gets a ton of hate like
people
genuinely don't gravitate towards him in
a positive manner yeah but I mean he he
was nice to me no he seems like a nice
dude but I'm saying did you did you give
him any advice did you guys have any
like side talks hey man how how you
liking this like cuz he is kind of like
an unofficial nek boy now or official
however you want to look at it mhm he's
part of the podcast yeah I get confused
what's what at this point anymore I
didn't I didn't have too much of a like
deep talk with him but we had a small
talk and he was cool but yeah I don't
even know if that's like I sometimes I
don't know if it's like a Persona he's
playing and then people will come at him
for that or if it's like I think he I I
don't think it is I think he's new to
the game that's what I think that's all
I can read happened for him quick yeah
and I think he's going all of it yeah
got dumped on his plate very fast and I
think anytime that happens to anybody no
matter where you're at it might be the
music industry entertainment
industry a lot it you know certain
people aren't built and I'm not saying
he's not but I'm saying like when that
much clout and fame gets just handed to
you 100% quickly man that's a lot no one
can prepare you for that nothing can you
just got to kind of get through it
that's why I would be the last person to
go on the p and [__] take shots at
steiny what about SEL do you do you ever
do you keep in contact with s at all
yeah a little bit yeah no one no one
it's it's not like a weekly thing or
anything but uh no all friendly he
trains uh jiujitsu so we've talked a few
times get him sparing in or something
but are you going to try to do [__] hole
again I think uh later down the road
it'd be cool like right now I'm worrying
about get this company profitable get
everything you know we're just grinding
right now that's all we're doing so and
my problem is that I start too many
projects so I'm trying to like narrow in
on what I'm what I'm focused on but uh I
think it would just be cool even if it's
not like a you know it doesn't make
sense financially to do it it's just if
we get to company a certain point for
the OG fans and I would love doing it
like I think it's so fun you enjoy yeah
just doing another season and building
that team out like and you guys do like
you're you're I mean like you know when
you when you did it last time you were
very much
uh it was a production value situation
yeah you guys were like there was actors
I mean I think of the um we were talking
about the Gramps guy and there was the
one episode where you were at a a biker
bar oh yeah with Chuck Liddell yeah with
Chuck Lidell which was [__] crazy but
I I think that like that's the way to do
it like I see I mean did you see this
kid that just got shot doing a prank in
the mall I heard about this [__]
crazy and like he's doing like some
Saleem type of [__] like yeah just
getting too close to someone's personal
space they tell him to stop he does it
again yeah got be careful with that and
the dude pulls out a gun and shoots him
[__] did he die he did not die that's
good but the dude who shot him they they
dropped the charges cuz they're like he
warned you like leave me alone and you
didn't and I think it might have been in
Florida now if that happened in
California that he'd be [__] yeah
Texas or Florida you're probably pretty
safe yeah in California if someone
breaks into your house and you shoot
them you're [__] you got to kindly ask
them to leave yeah I don't like that
about I love California but I love even
being a homeowner now I'm a little like
exactly this should be like my domain I
[__] work and a financially
successful person you probably have to
do a ton of gymnastics to you know make
sure you keep your money yeah 100% but
you come from Canada which from what I
understand there's high taxes in Canada
which is why there's great health
infrastructure and certain things right
yeah I can't even remember is it is it
Province by province in Canada dud I
don't [__] know I think it is all I
know is Ontario is definitely hot nobody
likes trto is what I've heard I've heard
that too and I know zero about politics
I specifically know all I know is you
can get free healthare and people don't
like Justin trau and he and he was
wearing black face and uh Jordan
Peterson is Uh something's going on with
his social media that [__] looks I don't
know enough to talk about it but cuz I
like Jordan Peterson but no I love
Jordan Peterson he's I I think I'm
stripping him with his [__] for like
just just for showing his perspective on
like podcast and I think in Canada
they're about to implement a law that
like
can there's some sort of law that there
the [__] Joe Rogan was talking about
it's like the essentially where they
they it affects your life if you say
talk about [__] that like they don't
social that social credit score [__] Joe
Rog always talking about exactly they're
doing that with Jordan Peterson if I'm
Jordan Peterson I'm [__] moving out
of Canada yeah I'm moving they love him
in Texas what yeah yeah yeah Jesus did
you guys ever like like
uh something off the Record well I I
will talk about it we'll delete it if
you don't want to talk about it but MH
when you had initially broken away you
and I were talking about you wanting to
start maybe like a Netflix style content
company MH and you were throwing around
some names that you were in talks with a
guy like Tim Dylan this was early on
before Tim Dylan was [__] huge yeah
um whatever happened with that and if
you don't want to talk about it it's
fine we'll cut it out but I know that
was like you know what I'm talking about
though trying to think of where that
conversation was we were talking about
so many ideas well we were we were just
like we were doing the pranks and [__]
and you were like man like you know I'm
I'm going to be doing like you wanted to
kind of have your own on demand content
[__] and you said that you were going to
start working with like certain
Comedians and [__] and I think Tim Dylan
might have been one of them that might
have been
under that might have been under nek I
think I think it was for sure it was for
sure sure cuz this was around that same
time where you were still filming on the
full send Channel I believe right yeah
yeah we were I think that was um
building uh pretty much like an R-rated
YouTube at the time was like so kind of
like Rumble yeah and but not so much
that everyone could upload on it it was
just another place you can go maybe it
is a pay wall like we were looking at a
bunch of things of just cuz I think at
the time when we were talking about that
it was we were getting strikes there was
there was a lot of [__] going on where
YouTube didn't look like a future home
for what we were doing and it was like
and we had a huge audience and we were
like why don't we just F what happens if
they do they do to Steve to you guys
yeah exactly it's like what do you did
you guys ever get any of your cuz I
always wonder if you get one of those
strikes is it even possible to get it
removed I can't remember I think it may
be time like a certain amount of yeah I
think it's like yeah if but I don't know
I know that once a channel gets flagged
and stried it's
none of the [__] whole pranks ever uh
got got hit in terms of probably some
copyright [__] and stuff but nothing
nothing serious I don't think I've ever
gotten a strike that's dope well uh what
so for you now where can people support
what you're doing obviously if you with
the IG the website how often are you
dropping how can how can people support
just on on YouTube if you want to like
follow the story we're building like you
said it's kind of cool to to and even
right now if you jump in I feel like
it's still the beginning stages and it
will be cool in 5 10 years to be like
damn I saw like the first people like
grinding this out but every Sunday we
upload an episode on uh the Sunday
Channel on YouTube and um yeah Sunday
Bloody Sunday Instagram what's what's
your guys' website uh bloody sunday.com
was that hard to get yeah how much was
it 25 Grand yeah it's not ter too bad 25
yeah who would you have to buy it off of
[__] I don't know like what what do you
know what it was before no I think it
was just someone sitting on domains y
such a great Hustle by the way yeah yo
that when you buy up
domains super selep on hustle oh yeah
cuz there's so many like web like
domains that you would think there's
some like you will go to like you'll
like type it like I remember one time I
was just tweaking with my boy not
literally tweaking on drugs but we're
just going to different like obvious
docs yeah we're like oh there's not like
someone's about to eat whenever this
comes out like Bloody Sunday yeah we
should start doing that Cyrus start
URLs just sitting on them I got a quote
for uh sunday.com which is [__]
obviously hard as [__] seven figures it
was uh they said 500k and up would be
you'd have to be like in that ballpark
to even start the conversation but
obviously at the time like I'm not
there's no need to do it but and right
now sunday.com is nothing um yeah we
have Sunday studios.com but I mean like
but Sunday right now the people who own
it if you go to sunday.com is it
something you know what's funny fun is
sunday.com isn't anything but if you
type in sunday.com it redirects you
to like another word Sunday and it's
like this that grass lawn company that's
called Sunday there's like a grass
fertilizer company oh so they don't
they're even using it it's I don't know
yeah I don't even know cuz it's it
redirects to another website but how
does that even make sense like it should
go to sunday.com and be like this
domain's for sale but it instantly
redirects so maybe they maybe they own
both and they haven't 500K you're going
to have to buy it if you guys get big
enough I think but I'd have to find the
I'd be more interested in the App Store
that'd be more um for my 10-year plan of
what I want to build here I think that
something kind of like what we were
talking about it's like something in the
world of building your own um
Subscription Service type thing and uh
and I think Sunday would be a great name
for that so great name yeah I mean if
you were to if you were to kind of say
hey Sunday is everything we have a
platform and the platform is sunday.com
yeah just the Simplicity of that Sunday
on the App Store [__] it's just a
color no logo like I think it there is
like I mean there's so many spider webs
to where I see this going in 10 years
but yeah that's definitely on the on the
horizon well listen like you said don't
take on too much at once yeah yeah one
thing at a time you have a lot going on
all right look go support uh I
appreciate you pulling back up man this
guy for a long time was a you know that
that interview you uh did for me man was
uh our most viewed interview for I think
it might still be really the single most
viewed upload the clip of you talking
about leaving nek was the I think it's
the single most viewed clip that's not a
short on our Channel still but right
place right time though I think it was
just yeah man conversation I appreciate
you coming through again man um yeah
[__] congrats on everything dude it's
just dope to kind of see like you know
uh I like when people reinvent
themselves you know and I think that the
brand is is Super Fly man so thanks man
appreciate it it's not cheesy you're
doing it the right way and uh yeah I
appreciate you bringing some gear and
stuff and um how often are you dropping
like new pieces for people to buy is it
monthly yeah it'll be every month
there's a new collection and uh and then
we also do a giveaway for one Sunday
skew every month and then you guys like
buried like a [__] giant wood box of
we get creative with it so we we
literally just Factor it as a tax on the
company meaning like we want to create
good culture and cool [__] and fun [__]
you could write it off like well not
even the write off it's almost like I'm
more saying a tax as in
like it's important for what I'm doing
here so like if I have to buy $10,000
worth of uh Sunday hoodies and just give
them away for free it's like [__] it
like you guys buried like a giant wooden
crate or two or three yeah in the desert
yeah just just like a beast of a [__]
crate yeah and it's only for the like on
Bloody sun.com when you go there it's
just a close sight but if you sign up
for email and SMS that's the only way
you get a part of it so you can get a
heads up where it might be yeah so like
so that month with a surprise was you
got three Clues slowly throughout the
week where you had to and then everyone
was trying to find out where it was is
it always in Cali the that giveaway yeah
no it's any it can be anywhere okay yeah
cuz I know you guys are you know based
here obviously yeah so I figured Cali or
yeah Palm Springs Joshua Tree you know
yeah was that where it was it was um no
real like Northern North from here I
can't even [__] remember it was like
some Dooms oh the dunes was that maybe
there Dunes everywhere but there's some
popular Dunes Glamis is the main one
that's like really big I luckily got out
of burying that one had some had some
goty for man all right well listen I
appreciate you pulling up Jesse man go
support my guy Bloody Sunday uh bloodys
sunday.com boom my guy [__] yeah fire
what's going on man I want to shout out
to our family a hardine for presenting
to you another interview all right
there's another interview coming
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day shout out to Hardin though if you're
in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to harden in
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they will get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg cev
show you say hey uh Harden I heard about
y'all on the bootleg cev podcast they're
going to take care of y'all all right so
go follow them Hardin Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
vegas.com what's up Harden